Yeah.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
And Ah,
I'm just checking on you.
I'm just checking out on you.
See now your weeks ago,
and I know if you live in Boston your weeks ago,
pretty good.
If you're living in Houston.
I echo so good.
Is it
fucking unbelievable how many times?
How many fucking times to fucking players on opposing teams just going to
fucking rile up the other team with some dumb horseshit?
Didn't you learn anything with Aaron judge and a very unfair and judge moment
playing fucking New York,
New York up in Boston
because they want,
they tied the fucking series.
What are you doing?
And then this other jackass on Houston
looking at some game film.
That's where they went back to back to back on fucking whatever.
Valdi whatevers.
I don't know what anybody's fucking name is.
Why the fuck would you do that?
I'm glad you keep doing it.
Stupid fucking moves.
You're the defending world series champions.
You don't need to be going around trying to fucking troll people.
You carry yourself with the quiet confidence of a champion.
That's what you supposed to do.
You don't fucking rile him up
so they can be in the other locker and gone into itself.
But those guys across the hall
then no respect you.
I mean,
oh,
it did.
Oh look what he said on fucking,
I'm fucking facetime.
Whatever the fuck these kids are doing.
And I know there's a lot of people down in Houston going like,
you know,
I don't know about that.
All to vague thing.
I think that was a fucking home run.
You know what?
I agree with you.
God knows they didn't have any angle.
We could definitively say it one way or another.
Look like he reached back into the stance.
I know Kate Upton thought that that's the way it went down and that's good
enough for me.
Um,
Kate Upton said Sofa players in the stands,
fans are supposed to move over.
Those are the rules.
Mlb shouldn't let fans sit there.
They didn't reach over the fence.
Okay.
You know,
who would've thought Kate Upton was that into the fucking game is great.
Um,
anyways,
I thought,
oh,
I thought it was a,
I mean,
every angle that I saw,
which was not nothing definitive,
I could see why they didn't overturn it.
I was surprised we got that call.
But that's not why the Astros lost the game.
I hate when people do that.
Well he missed a field goal in the first quarter and a,
they lost by two.
So I mean if he hits that,
that they,
uh,
they were the fuck no,
the [inaudible] fucking hits.
It changes the whole game.
Did you watch back to the future?
He can't go.
He can't go back changing things.
It changes the future.
The reason why you fucking lost is because you let up eight runs.
Yeah.
Why did you let a bait runs?
Cause you're on fucking social media fucking amping up the red sox.
They've got a little more spring in their steps going.
I'm sorry.
Did they not respect the fact that we want 108 fucking games
then Jackie Bradley Jr has got to go up there and get the old right there.
Fred,
what does,
um,
anyways,
I still,
you know,
I still think this thing is far from over.
All right.
You're probably thinking,
Hey,
bill,
while you're up three games to one,
why would you say that?
Because I remember 2004 when there was a fucking $200 million team up,
three games to none and they did win.
So it's still,
we till we put the final nail in the fucking coffin,
you know?
Uh,
that's it.
And by the way,
who was the fucking country and how the fuck did you figure out how the fuck did
they figure out the name of the guy?
Some random fucking guy,
not one credit on IMD B.
How do they find out what his fucking name was?
And then why would you go ahead and publish it after?
What happened to that poor bastard?
Uh,
what's his name?
Oh,
Mikey.
Michael said up there in the Chicago cubs.
That guy when fucking him in for the people I reached up for the ball.
He just so happened he hit him.
Whatever the hell his name is.
I'm glad I forgot what his fucking name is.
I hope that guy has been able to move on with his life.
The guy to hire fucking hide under the old Comiskey stadium for the last
fucking,
I dunno,
15 years now that the cubs won it will you finally stopped taking your childhood
out on this guy.
That fucking guy in the front row did what everybody else would do.
Do you realize the balls it takes to fucking stick your hand out there?
You ever see?
You ever buy cattle foul ball?
Some.
It's a fucking baseball.
Would you go play baseball with your friend?
The guy who's just building an APP with no,
with no glove.
Would you do that?
Leave the guy the fuck alone.
That's like some shit that morning.
Fucking radio guys trying to be edgy.
They're the kind of people they fucking
put the person's name out.
There's poor bastard.
He goes,
okay.
You know I got to get security the Astros lose this game.
I'm going to need security escort me out of here.
The Astros don't come back and win.
This match is fucking,
that's pathetic.
You know what about the other pitchers given up all those runs?
Huh?
Do they have security escort them out of the building?
Well I guess they do.
How
about that cash for Ben attending and the game unfucking believable.
So having said that,
uh,
the Houston Astros still scare the shit out of me cause they are the defending
world series champions.
They've got a couple of fucking uh,
you know,
tough games here.
But I figured Verlin has got to be coming back any moment to put it on his white
hat and come back in and save the day,
try to make it three,
two then all of a sudden they're like,
why,
you know,
all we got to do is one,
one more now it's fucking tied up and ads anybody series.
That's how quickly you can fucking turn around.
It's no different than getting married.
You know,
you're a single man,
you've got the world by the balls and any second you could just fall in love
with a woman and all that freedom you had all that time,
all those great feelings you felt about yourself,
all those dumb sports shorts,
shorts,
sports shirts that you had that you thought were cool.
All of a sudden they just disappear.
You just like,
you're in seventh grade.
I liked seventh grade,
honey,
just try on this button down and it all fucking goes away.
Don't ever forget that.
You know,
it's like a fucking squirrel,
right?
Goes off and gets a couple of nuts.
It's fucking lolly gag.
And across the road,
all of a sudden a hammer comes along,
right?
Just fucking flats the thing.
I haven't,
no,
I'm talking about right now.
I just can't,
I'm just stunned that were up three games to one.
Um,
hopefully Joel Olsteen we'll fucking open the doors to his church and let some
people in there,
you know,
let that guy fucking hide in there.
Joel opened the fucking door on eight security.
Is it raining up?
Jesus doesn't want you to come in if it's raining out.
Um,
all right,
enough of that shit.
We still got one more to go.
Uh,
having said that,
I,
I still love the fucking Astros and I love their fans.
It's like I haven't seen them this fucking amped up.
You know,
since those great late seventies teams with Jay are Richards and all that.
And I love when I see the old school gay pride parade will flag that they used
to have.
Um,
it was actually more like the gay pride,
like ginger flag.
Like if you were,
if you like gay people,
but only redheaded once that was like,
you had a flag for it,
that's what their Jersey looked like.
Um,
all right,
here's one for you.
I've been in New York City,
I'm in,
I'm in Baltimore now.
Baltimore,
Scarface,
reference anybody.
Um,
I got two shows tonight at the lyric theater and then I fucking got Atlantic
city.
I got two more.
And then I see my daughter for the first time in a week.
This has been fucking brutal,
but I had to do it cause I gotta fucking try.
And,
uh,
you know,
I got a hype these Goddamn gigs.
So,
um,
anyway,
I'm doing the whole fucking run yesterday,
six feet,
six 15 in the morning until seven at night.
Just run in my fucking Yap about Madison Square Garden and dude,
every fucking,
every,
almost every fucking interview.
Almost every fucking interview is just like,
so what do you mean,
do you think
about,
uh,
Louis C K coming back?
You know,
it's still predominantly white.
Which would you say that it's a predominantly white male?
Patriarchal.
Wha what?
What do you feel Jen?
Abortion.
Essentially,
what am I fucking running for office here?
You know all these fucking comedians that want to talk about that shit just
cause they're talking about all of that Shit and getting all political and
fucking
dive in into this,
dividing the country down the fucking middle.
I just sitting there like,
why do I have to,
why do I have to comment on this?
So I'll let,
I'll let you guys on a little fucking inside 10 think of,
sorry,
I don't have my microphone.
So sorry about the fucking breathing on them.
Like they're,
um,
I'll let you in on a little fucking secret.
This is how I handle those questions.
They'll go like,
so what do you think about Louis CK coming back?
I just go,
I dunno.
What do you think about it?
Yeah.
It fucking works every time.
Either they either,
they go,
well,
no,
I'm asking you.
I'm like,
well,
I go,
I wasn't thinking about you.
You're obviously thinking about it.
You obviously have an opinion.
I would love to hear your opinion.
That fascinates me.
What do you think about it?
Or You just go,
I don't know.
What do you think about it in the book?
You know,
I take a jet tickets,
fine Merr already tickets bullshit or whatever,
and then I just sit there and I look over and I fucking look at my butt.
You know,
the guy taken me around the radio and it just smiling
the fuck.
Do I take what I take?
I want to be still be able to make my mortgage this month,
if you don't mind.
Okay.
Fucking unbelievable.
I don't understand how this is a more progressive era where,
and things are getting better.
That if,
if you haven't done anything,
even if you comment in the wrong fucking way,
all of a sudden you're in trouble and they take your fucking show away.
I just,
I like it's,
it's fucking ridiculous.
And I know that I am in the massive majority when I say that,
right?
Jesus fucking Christ.
We might have people that I saw on this fucking trip,
that old friends I haven't seen yet.
You know,
women,
are you going to hug him?
You're like,
oh,
well this,
you know the fire I want to,
I'm going to come up with a fucking me to stick the thing where you go in for
the hug and then if you feel fucking weird,
it just fucking,
it's like a nerf sticker up that it just shoots out between the two of you.
I'm bringing it back,
the fist bump.
But you know,
current comedy climate,
what do you,
is it hard is it can be
[inaudible] current claim.
All right,
if I hear that one more fucking time.
It's like what fucking shows go to a comedy show.
People are just showing up in the laughing.
They're adults.
They know you're there at a show.
Yeah,
I know these fucking assholes.
What kind of a fucking adult goes to a comedy show and then goes,
you know,
I was triggered by that show.
You were triggered.
Well,
toughen the fuck up.
Stay home.
All right,
go,
go watch a willy Wonka and the in the,
in the fucking chocolate factory.
Go Watch that shit.
Go Watch.
Go.
Go fucking home and go watch a muppet movie.
Okay.
You went outside,
you went in public,
you said fucking down in a comedy club.
It's the job of the comedian to say crazy outrageous shit and make you laugh.
You know,
go get,
go with the fucking ice capades that's in a country.
Most of those,
you know,
usually when they have the star,
the star of the thing is usually a fucking Olympic gold medal winner.
Way Back in the day.
The fuck was her name.
Donna Karen.
Who was that chicken one in [inaudible] 76 I remember she called in sick that
day.
We went to go see Dorothy Hamill.
There's a great old name on Dorothy.
Dottie.
What do you mean you're not fucking skate?
And at the fucking Boston Garden,
we got into a bunch of mascots out there looking for a pretty chicken.
You ain't out there toiling around
the ice.
Capades trigger me because my last relationship,
my boyfriend was ice cold to me.
Yeah.
Is there any way you could melt the ice and give me my money back?
Um,
anyway,
so I'm doing all this fucking doing all of this press.
I wasn't all like that,
but there was a,
there was a lot of fucking talking about the current climate.
Um,
I'll be honest if you come into my show is I've been going harder than ever and
I've been trashed feminist because it's fun.
MMM.
And I agree with,
you know,
a lot of this,
you want to make shitty equal like yet it,
it's fine.
Does that mean I have to lose my job because I have a fucking opinion about
something?
Huh?
All right.
They have bushy
anyways,
so going around right.
And all of these fucking goddamn buildings,
you go into the,
you know,
they want like you're fucking driver's license and shit like you going into the
Goddamn Pentagon.
So I just show it to them.
And now that they let they like take the thing from you and they stick it in
this little ass fucking computer things,
scan it or all I was dumb shit.
And you know,
they're taking all your information off of it.
So I have an expired license,
right?
I have one that's not expired,
but I kept my expired one and that's the one I give it.
I give to them.
Right?
It's fucking from way back in the day when I still had fucking heroin at a
different address.
Right?
So I fucking go to this building and I hand it to the guy and he goes,
your ids expired.
I go,
yeah,
but my face is it,
you know,
I,
I didn't come here to drive the building.
You know,
it's a fucking id.
You need an,
there's an I date and I'm telling you these guys,
pretty soon it's gonna be,
you need a valid id to go.
It's like you have to know where the fuck I live.
That goes back to this fucking guy
who just like,
who caught that,
you know that home run.
And now he's sitting there going,
I'm going to meet this poor past has got it.
Thinking about his own personal safety,
like I don't understand how these corporations and all these people are able to
snag your personal information.
People have stalkers but get all the women out there who literally have to have
like,
like restraining orders from these Luna Tech guys and these fucking corporations
that you're going to buy fucking chap stick.
You know,
they,
they double swipe you love whatever the fuck they do with you.
God Damn license.
They take your fucking information and they just put it out there
and you know what's going to happen is somebody's going to get fucking killed
because of it.
And then these corporations,
they're not going to be responsible.
I,
I dunno,
I dunno.
I'm just basically,
I'm just fucking,
I'm shouting into a tornado here.
Nobody gives a fuck.
And if you dumb fucks are going to go onto that ancestry.com and then we're all,
all of our fucking DNA is going to be mapped.
You know what I mean?
Like in what,
what good is going to come with that?
They'll catch a couple of Syrah killers.
Okay.
What else are they going to do?
I'm telling you I'm doing that whole bet.
They're going to fucking build your robot replacement.
Oh,
who knows what?
I don't know.
I just don't understand what people have against privacy now.
You know it's fucking,
you see the look of concern or this guy's,
this guy's put full fucking poor bashed his face.
This poor guy in Houston,
he's probably thinking,
how the fuck am I going to get to my goddamn horse and ride out of fucking town
without these mother fuckers getting a posse together coming after me?
MMM.
Anyways,
I don't know when the next game is,
but uh,
people can we,
can we try to stop yelling at each other?
You know,
can we fucking stop trying to peer into everybody's fucking living room?
These fucking lunatics like the fucking Alexis Shit.
What kind of a fucking moron gets that?
You have literally bugging your own house house.
Sorry,
was yelling at the TV last night.
I'm watching the game.
You literally bug in your own house.
You're sending your DNA into the fucking Internet.
Oh at,
or what else are you gonna do?
You're gonna fucking handcuff your risk to your ankles.
Start walking backwards down the street and see what happens to me.
What are you doing?
It's,
it's just so you can have some fucking thing
and you and you and you goddamn house.
So you could be like a,
you know,
captain and Tennille.
What was the captain's Alexis?
What was the captain's real name?
Okay.
Through the fucking shit that I say when I'm in my house to try and make my wife
laugh.
I made,
I don't want anybody here on that.
I mean,
that's,
that's our own private fucking jokes.
Then forget about what I get to a God damn argument.
The shit that I say.
Well it's the,
why the fuck would you do somebody's recording that?
Who's listening to it
at this gotta be somebody on the other side that Alexis Alexa,
whatever the fuck it is,
is literally listening to your life like a reality show.
You know,
maybe it was like an FBI guy or a fucker.
One of those international fucking Gumshoe guys and they're listening.
Maybe set a couple of fucking a,
you know,
you were trying to talk about form of President Obama and you said Osama
instead,
and that was a trigger thing.
So now they got to listen in on your life to make sure you're not fucking,
you know,
a terrorist or some shit.
Right.
And then they just,
I dunno,
they just listening.
They don't hear any terrorist shit,
but they just kind of get into your life.
Oh,
he's,
yeah,
they were expecting a child.
This is,
oh,
this is so exciting.
I'm so sick of being in this van and they just fucking listens.
Uh,
you know,
do you like on like one of those flat screen TVs?
You know,
they got the cameras on and like they got,
they ask them,
do you watch people in their houses watching TV?
And I don't know why they didn't just say no.
They would like,
uh,
you know,
we're not going to comment on that or something.
Let me,
let me fucking look that shit up.
Here we go.
What is it right here?
Um,
smart TVs.
Watch you watching you.
All right,
here we go.
This side,
it'd be great for my fucking paranoia.
Para know yourself.
Destroy.
Yeah.
Your smart TV is watching you watching TV.
Consumer report fines.
Now,
why isn't this
a concern to anybody?
You know
you're smart.
TV is watching you watch TV,
consumer report fines.
All right?
Millions of smart TVs sitting and families living them are vulnerable to hackers
taking control.
Oh,
this is saying hackers and could be tracking the households personal viewing
habits much more closely than their owners realize according to a new consumer
reports investigation.
Um,
all right,
so this is talking about hackers then that's,
I'm talking about the actual fucking companies.
All right?
So if hackers
like one,
this is like fucking,
I mean that's like a,
that's has be a crime,
right?
I Dunno.
These fucking voyeurs these days is so god Damn Lazy.
Back in the day,
if someone wanted to look at you,
they had to walk up to your window,
right?
And you saw him coming up your yard,
but they're fucking dick out.
And you had a time to grab like a steak knife for something or maybe a shotgun.
You came out,
you brandished a weapon and the guide,
you know,
ran away may not too fast,
cause you can only run so fast with the fucking erection.
And that's usually how people got caught.
Yeah.
Um,
but now they can just stay,
just stay at home.
Eight o'clock,
they start knowing you fucking habits a is just a couple of banks every Friday
night around nine o'clock,
when they,
you know,
kids all go out.
The kids are older.
Sit down.
Wow.
Look at that and doggy style this week.
Oh,
they added something else.
The ripple to have this little fucking TV show much.
I don't know.
The whole thing fucking freaks me out.
Um,
what,
what is people's fascination with that shit?
Why do you want to listen?
Why do you want to look at people?
What the fuck do you care?
Maybe because I'm antisocial,
I don't get it.
Like,
you know what I mean?
My wife's social,
she says hi to the neighbors and that shit,
I'm,
if I'm like,
I'm just like,
Hey Aria,
I go inside.
I don't care what you're doing.
I don't want to what?
Know what you're doing.
I don't want to watch your fuck.
I don't want to see what she eating and I don't want,
I don't want to see your arguments.
I could barely talk to you in my fucking driveway.
The fuck would,
I won't get up.
I'm going to,
I'm going to fucking watch that.
I'm going to learn how to hack into somebody's TV or I could put on a Martin
Scorsese movie instead.
Yeah man.
But Alexis is real man.
I Dunno.
It's all fucking this whole podcast.
They'll hold worlds.
He's fucking weirded me out.
Now I'll tell you this.
Current climate,
let me read this.
Felix Gray,
which sounds like a,
a high,
like a Hollywood escort service,
doesn't it?
Felix Gray.
Can I help you?
Yeah,
I want a red head.
I want a Brunette.
All right,
Felix.
Sorry.
Felix Gray.
Uh,
the average American blast,
their eyes with bright screens for 11 hours every fucking day.
All these things are great.
I actually have a pair of these.
He's amazing.
Now you can protect your eyes and not wearing them cause I'm a moron.
Have them at home.
Now you can protect your eyes with a pair of Felix gray glasses available with
or without a prescription.
Felix gray glasses filter out 90% of high energy.
I love that percentage.
I always go with that percentage.
90% of high energy,
blue light and eliminate the glare coming off all those screens.
That means no more tired eye.
You can have your tab,
boom,
boom and you're blur.
Revision is a thin this guys all right or headaches
[inaudible] usually it seems like a hassle to have to protect your eyes man and
that's why most of us don't do it,
but Felix gray glasses aren't like those weird computer glasses you've seen
before.
There's no yellow Lens Tint.
Donny shut the fuck up.
That's what I always think of when I think yellow.
I love of a finger here in an hour.
Felix gray glasses are handcrafted from premium Italian acetate,
Acetate,
so they won't make you look nerdy.
In fact,
throwing on some Felix Graze is an easy way to look pretty put together.
Sorry Felix.
Grays glasses are available in non prescription prescription and readers with
free shipping and free returns.
There's nothing to lose.
Don't go another day.
Looking at screens without the help of some Felix Graze.
Go to Felix gray glasses.com/burr to protect your eyes today.
That's Felix Gray Glasses,
g,
r,
a y for all you dummies out there.
A F,
e l I,
x,
G,
r a y,
glasses.com/ [inaudible] and you go,
that might be my favorite Eagle Song.
Um,
and there's a lot of them
staying in and on the corner.
Winslow,
Arizona,
such a fine sight to see.
It's an l two vague fucking ball going into the fucking stands.
Hold on baby.
You're out.
Take a seat.
I can't believe how many calls Boston teams get now.
It's like they're making up for the entire last century roughing the passer.
Go Fuck yourself and your super bowl drapes.
Right?
Then all of a sudden it just turned around.
Everything just fucking has been going our way.
I don't know what happened
from bill by Tom Brady.
Brady.
Wait a minute.
The tuck rule.
You're going to the Superbowl,
Alex Rodriguez slapping that ball out and Mincaye his hand.
We never got those calls.
Yeah,
you're out.
You can't fucking do that.
But he's wearing pin stripes.
That's over
fucking God damn Canadians.
Are they losing the game man.
Fucking too many men in the ice.
Gila floor right there.
Fred.
No Stanley Cup for you,
sir.
My whole fucking life.
It's unbelievable.
I'm just going to enjoy the shit out of it.
The same way.
Any other fan?
What if everything was going his way?
That's another thing they always asked me on these sports shows,
don't you?
I,
you're excited.
I mean,
with all these titles,
as it says,
it's still exciting.
I mean,
I,
I w I would be bored.
Well,
I'm not,
I'm enjoying the shit out of it,
but thank you for your concern.
Thank you for asking.
I know it's coming from a place of jealousy.
Okay.
I know when things are said,
when they're not coming from a place of love,
the way Kate Upton was,
Kate Upton loves baseball.
Who knew she and after or she'll model.
She a model turned actor.
The fuck is Kate Upton.
I know that.
I know she's some ridiculously beautiful woman.
You know I'm more than that bill.
I'm also a baseball fan.
Sorry.
All right.
Kate Upton.
Jesus Christ.
I couldn't draw more.
I can't really drop it.
If I could dry kid draw better looking in person than that.
What's it like to be that good looking?
You must just like stare at yourself in them or she got the same birthday as me.
Oh my God.
Maybe I have a chance.
Alexis.
Who?
Kate Upton go out with me.
No.
All right.
Kate.
Elizabeth [inaudible] is an American model and actress Upton was named the
sports illustrated states sports illustrated swimsuit issue rookie of the year.
Oh my God.
That's it.
Fucking over.
Can you imagine being that fucking good looking?
Why was that good looking?
If I was like Brad Pitt,
good looking,
I would literally be like Ron Burgundy.
I'd be like,
hey,
one cupboard.
See?
Oh God,
I look.
Yeah,
and know he's at my eyebrows up a little bit.
When I looked to the side.
Oh I,
you know,
I,
I would be,
that would be very generous with my good looks.
I would,
I wouldn't be like one of these people rolling their eyes like,
oh my God,
I get it.
Stop staring at me.
Can you just [inaudible] I wouldn't be like that at all.
Be walking around with half shirts and shit.
Eight pack everybody.
Well,
you take it in anatomy class.
You can see over on the entire,
all the whole,
the whole midsection is put together here.
Um,
by the way,
I've been eating like shit out here in the road.
My flat stomach is no more.
I looked like a fucking Turd.
Dakota.
MMM.
All right.
You know what Kate Upton looks like?
I look like the exact opposite.
Um,
oh my God,
I look like a fucking redheaded Danny Devito.
Oh fuck.
I just,
you know,
I got here and it's just like I got one of those New York Deli sandwiches and I,
I just,
you don't,
you feel like you have to stock up because I know I'm going back out.
Like,
if I was going to move,
ever move back to the east coast,
like the amount of fucking Mexican food that I would be eating in La,
the amount of Taco trucks that I would hit,
the amount of Thai food,
the amount of Burgers,
everything that La does.
Great.
I go up to San Francisco,
I'd get a couple of thousand fucking burritos
shoving down my fat fuck a fucking throat,
you know?
And then that would be it.
And,
and I would,
I would just head back east and I would never get another fucking Taco.
It's like I'm not doing it.
Um,
I mean pizza.
I mean,
how do you lay off pizza in Italian food when you're back here?
Cause I can't do it because I got to go back to,
to no man's land of Shit,
bread,
shit,
doe and all of that stuff.
So whatever.
I'll get back on the Diet.
I'm going to do that three day water fast.
You know
where you just drink water and you don't consult a doctor and then all of a
sudden you go into convulsions and then you come to in the hospital
and there's some guy fucking the stethoscope standing over Vigo in.
Uh,
that was a pretty a reckless thing.
You did.
What happened?
Well,
you let your electrolytes get down to la.
She ever challenged him any less than a year,
a bile juices and hey,
what happened was the,
uh,
the lining of your cell walls.
Uh,
if you take too much water,
I just,
hey buddy,
could you just fucking,
am I still alive right now or am I in hell because I don't know what the fuck
you talking about.
Okay,
I get it.
Can I see a mirror?
But see how much weight I lost?
How long was he in a coma for?
Was it like a liquid diet and you couldn't force me to chew where you,
I'm a big Hollywood phony.
I don't care if I almost killed myself.
I'm just trying to lose weight.
I'm trying to keep my Michelle entire fucking,
do you know if somebody told me that the,
I didn't know Michelin Stars were the same people who make the tires.
Yeah.
For those of you,
uh,
uncultured people,
a Michelin Star,
the coveted Michelin Star,
you know,
if you get three of those,
which is such a weird thing cause it's usually usually have to get like four,
five star hotel,
you know,
five star hotel is done is the new four.
Right.
But Michelin,
it's like three stars.
It's got three Michelin Stars and that means that the food evidentaly is out of
this fucking world.
Okay.
And I found out that
I thought there was separate,
you know,
like there's the Macintosh stereo and then there's the Macintosh computer and
they're spelled differently and they have nothing to do with each other.
That's what I thought.
A Michelin Star Wars.
I'm like,
yeah,
but it's not literally the fucking Michelin tire people.
It is.
And this person had to look it up cause I refuse to believe it.
And I was just like,
but why the fuck are we listening to these people?
They make tires,
you know,
I mean that's just a weird thing.
I see tires and then you're into like a also breaks or something else on a
fucking car.
Steering columns.
Something in the tire area.
Okay.
You know,
how the fuck do you go from radial tires helping me not hydroplane to a beef
Borgen y'all like where the fuck I was supposed to go to photo.
Fuck does Michelin think they are and furthermore,
what's wrong with all of these fucking,
what do you call them?
The,
the God damn ma chefs getting all fucking nervous about what a tire company
thinks.
That would be like a bunch of comedians getting nervous
about uh,
making one comedian make them fucking nervous.
Yeah.
All right,
I'm speaking to code here.
Okay.
Anyways,
ladies and gentlemen,
that is the podcast.
Uh,
I got two shows tonight here in Baltimore.
If you're in the area,
come on down.
And um,
then I have to at the Borgata and then I'm flying home immediately that goes
hang out with my lovely wife,
my beautiful daughter,
and I ain't doing shit until the following weekend.
And even then,
I'm only leaving for one day.
Okay.
And then I have Madison Square Garden on Wednesday,
November 7th,
and then I have a three days at the unbelievably,
okay.
Beautiful.
Um,
Chicago theater and then,
you know,
something all freckles fucking year on the road is over
except for one charity Gig.
I have to do.
Other than that,
I'm done.
All right.
And I am,
I am going to get myself,
I'm going to lose.
He's this fucking 10 pounds I think I put on in the last three days.
Oh,
I had a good time.
I had a good time doing it though.
Yeah.
There's a few places that I go back to and it's like,
I just go back to where the fuck I want.
Like whenever I go back to Boston,
it's just over.
I go to all the places that I went to when I,
when I could eat McDonald's at four in the morning,
still wake up and not have no damage done.
Really.
And when I go to New York,
I,
she's just like,
I'm,
I'm not going to get a bacon,
egg and cheese sandwich on a fucking role.
Every goddamn data.
How do I lay off that?
Well,
Bill,
you have willpower.
I know.
Fucking I'm streaky.
That's how I am.
All right.
Anyways,
go red sox.
Go Patriots.
Go Bruins,
go Celtics.
This is this great time of year where they're all playing at the same time.
Um,
astro fans.
Be Nice to that guy.
All right.
He did what we all would've done.
I would've done the same fucking thing.
Actually me,
I've already got out of the way cause I want to go to get what?
The fucking ball.
Um,
but uh,
don't,
don't be a bunch of cans.
All right.
If you take anything
yeah.
From this podcast,
how cool is it?
The Kate Upton likes fucking baseball at that level.
Yeah.
Okay.
It's about time.
One of the swimsuit models in sports illustrated actually watch sports.
Yeah,
look great though.
I'm sure she's fucking thrilled that she has your,
all right.
Please enjoy the music,
uh,
on the podcast here.
And,
um,
that's it.
And then we'll play another half hour of greatest hits from a Thursday afternoon
podcast just before Friday with the Monday,
somewhere in there from earlier this year,
maybe
five minutes ago.
[inaudible] long
distance hiking.
The last week I mentioned that I went on a hike and we just kept going and going
like assholes,
not realizing that we had to walk back.
Hiking is not like a treadmill.
You don't just get to step off and be like,
oh,
I'm still,
despite the fact I walked for an hour,
I am still only,
you know,
10 paces from my phone,
the parking lot,
my car.
Um,
we ended up going on like an 11 mile hike and uh,
it was exhausting to say the least.
So this person is writing about long distance hiking,
another great old man thing to do yoga,
hockey,
ice hockey,
and a hiking,
you know.
Um,
all right.
Hey Bill,
I've been listening to your podcast long enough to know that you love hiking,
you hate getting fat and you get easily annoyed by day to day bullshit.
I really think you'd enjoy backpacking out.
Jesus
backpacking.
I know it's awesome,
but can you call it something else?
Backpacking.
I just feel like I'm fucking waiting for a bus,
picking my nose by really get the shit kicked out of me.
Hey,
you guys want to go backpacking to pack?
You put on your back and you go backpacking or long distance hiking.
Okay,
let's call it that.
It's a really,
I don't have long distance hiking freaks me out because I figured at that point
you've walked long enough to run into something that can mall you to death slash
rip your face off or at the very least just sort of bite your throat until it
stops feeling the pulse,
you know,
start getting into that next weight class of animals and I don't know,
mountain lions,
black bear,
grizzly bear,
fucking Anaconda,
whatever.
Exotic pet that somebody let loose that has no natural enemy that is now taking
over the forest.
Um,
longest or long distance hiking.
It's really,
it's really freeing to walk away from civilization for a week or more with the
solid pair of boots and everything you need strapped to your back,
dude.
Fuck that.
You're more man or woman than I am.
I,
I can't fucking deal with that.
I get scared.
I get,
I get freaked the fuck out.
I'd have to be out there with somebody who knew what they were doing.
Who had a gun.
Uh,
automatic to not even semiautomatic.
I need something that I could spray and the general direction of the sound I
just heard and you know,
if we kill a couple of backpackers,
there's no one else around burying them as optional.
I would say leave them above ground cause they'll get picked away a lot quicker
than people will find their clothes.
I guess the bones would be there.
That's creepy.
See what happens when you go out in the wilderness,
you start fucking talking about shit like that.
I live in a suburb.
Okay.
There's plenty of people to shoot and I never think of donut.
They're right out there.
Right fucking out there and I never think of shooting him.
All of a sudden you get me backpacking or long distance hiking and I'm trying to
think how to bury bodies.
All right.
Every time I finish a long hike,
I come back looking healthier and leaner and feeling refreshed.
Yeah.
Cause you were out there eating berries,
wiping your ass with fucking pine cones.
That's it.
That's why you have that peculiar look on your face.
No matter how much you eat on the trail,
you're guaranteed to lose weight.
If you spend six hours a day hiking with a 35 pound backpack,
there's no need to limit yourself to salads and juice.
I can't tell you how many times I've had older day hikers look at my backpack
and tell me they wish they had done more backpacking when they were able to.
It's a really unique experience.
Experienced out there on your own.
Yeah,
I bet it is.
Well,
what do,
can you please write back and tell me,
uh,
what you do about animals,
man,
because I'm telling you right now,
I'm not doing this.
You know,
I,
the only way I would do this is I was in a fucking platoon and we all had
machine guns just in case I missed.
Um,
anyways,
oh,
here he goes.
He's going to calm me down.
And it isn't nearly as dangerous or as difficult as people make it out to be.
If you stay on the trail,
you'll usually run across another hiker every few hours.
Oh,
that's comforting.
That's comforting.
Every couple hours I can run into Johnny Appleseed,
but during the other hour and 50 minutes minutes,
I'm on my own.
All right.
Ah,
you're running usually run into another hike or every few hours that can help
you.
If you get hurt and bears mountain lions and all those other beasts kill a lot
fewer people than Los Angeles.
Traffic accidents do.
Well,
I used to do a bit on that.
obviously,
because the fucking,
you know the,
there's,
you're running into one person every two hours,
sir.
Let's do the math here.
Okay?
Yeah.
Here's the deal.
There's like 7 million people in Los Angeles.
Okay.
You can't fucking go anywhere without running into like a thousand fucking
people out here.
You're somewhere where you walk every two hours and run into one human beings.
So obviously I can guarantee you if those lines and mountain lines were down
here,
the death rate would be through the fucking roof.
All right?
This is the guy,
this is what he says too.
He goes,
just keep your food away from your tent and you'll be fine.
Do you understand,
sir,
that you're telling me to do something where if I'm too near my food supply,
I could possibly get eaten to death.
You want me to leave my living room?
Do you know why can't I just sit on my back porch?
Well,
listen,
I would love,
I,
I would love to too.
Go hiking like that.
I,
I really would,
but I cannot get past.
MMM,
no,
I don't think you should be able to get past it.
That there's,
that type of shit is out there.
All right.
And if you get mauled to death as a standup comedian,
yeah.
You really were just looking for trouble,
aren't you?
I,
that's,
you know,
somebody just asked me to do a cruise to do stand up on a cruise and I,
I told him I wasn't going to do it.
And they said,
why not?
And I said,
because I'm terrified of the ocean.
Okay?
That's why I don't,
I respect it.
The ocean is not the ocean is the ocean,
but it's,
it's literally you're talking about
it's outer space on earth.
That's what it is,
okay?
You can't breathe in it.
You're not.
You can't be in it.
If you're in it too long,
you're either going to get hypothermia or something's going to come up and take
a bite out of yet to see if your edible
or are you going to drown.
Those are your three fucking options.
And I know what you're thinking,
dude,
cruisers to safe,
man,
you're out there on this big fucking boat yet.
And until you're not until you're not,
and then you proceed to die.
One of the slowest,
most terrifying fucking deaths that there is treading water in the middle of
fucking nowhere and somebody's going to die.
No matter how fast they can fucking get you out there that somebody is going to
die and people follow.
I fucking would did one cruise in my life and I could not,
I couldn't get past the fact that I was on something that the second it fucking
shits the bed.
And I know you guys think that you go,
I've been on cruises and go fuck yourself.
I talked to the,
that was on this cruise ship for fucking years and they told me stories over a
little fucking played a Jello late at night.
Those awful cruise desserts.
So poor excuse for fucking,
I also,
I don't like fucking going out there and all of a sudden it's maritime laws and
this Douche bag who didn't even run for office is now telling me what the he,
whatever he says goes with his stupid ass fucking outfit.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Um,
they told me stories.
Okay.
They told me,
they told me enough fucking stories about food poisoning,
about shit backing up about uh,
one engine not working.
Yeah.
And now they're going half speed and then they don't make it to all the cities.
And then they make up shit about hurricanes and then they have,
fuck it.
Trust me.
People have medical issues.
And having to be fucking helicoptered off and flown is quickly.
Is Human possibly possible?
Not to the best possible hospital to the nearest one.
All right,
and are you going on a cruise?
They go all over the fucking world and they go buy a bunch of fucking countries
that you wouldn't want to fucking get,
have I've ever Goddamn hangnail in,
but all of a sudden they're the closest one.
And that's where the fuck you're going.
Dole.
Hey Doctor Harry Hackett off.
Fuck that.
All right.
Fucking combined.
Stand up comedy and waterworld.
I'm not doing it.
All right.
So that's the thing about,
I would absolutely love to go backpacking.
I would love to do that.
I would love to go up fucking mountains.
It's way better than going to the gym.
I understand 100% what you're talking about,
but do that shit where you run into a bear mama bear and it just,
yeah,
turns around and just runs it.
You 35 40 miles an hour,
you basically,
and you're sitting there hearing this does beast
like trees getting out of the fucking way.
It's this thing is just coming,
flying down the fucking hill at you and you're running knowing you're going to
get caught and you're here in your stupid pots and pans,
clink,
clank and together and all you're trying to do is just get out in front of your
friend.
So he's the one that goes down and so you can live knowing for the rest of your
life what your strategy did.
Killed your friends here in his cries
whenever enough.
What is the sound of having your face ripped off?
I like to lose weight like the next guy.
Jesus,
you go out there with your beer,
you're fucking bear mace.
Fuck.
All of that.
Bears.
Mountain lions,
poisonous snakes.
What about if you just,
and then all the fucking varmints out there.
I love that word because you send me Sam's the only person I ever heard use it.
And when I found out it was actually a credible word,
not something made up.
I absolutely loved that word farm.
It's,
you know,
badgers,
wolverines,
bobcat's people will get bobcat's like they're no big deal if you're getting
scratched by a fucking house cat,
how bad that,
that thing can fuck you up with its little ass.
Fucking pause.
All right.
You,
you want a goddamn links jumping on.
You go to fucking town cause it's board or you're freaked out.
You came near to near something that had peed on and you have no fucking idea.
That's another thing,
dude,
you're,
you're in their world.
This guy actually actually respected the fact that I said I'm not doing it,
but I also,
he,
I think he thought it was pretty peculiar that I,
I wouldn't do a stand up on a cruise.
I just jumped subjects.
Sorry.
And uh,
and I was waiting for him to ask me why.
And I would just be like,
well,
you know,
would you do a podcast,
in on a,
on a boat in a lake that's full of fucking alligators.
I mean you can like,
okay,
we're on the boat,
everything's fucking fine,
but it's really is just an unnecessary risk that you take.
Goes all the way back to that fucking saints fan.
He got off easy.
That same fucking guy put that guy with his Jersey with his video cam camera
walking up to a mama bear screaming who day,
who day and all that type of shit and he's worried about getting spit in his
face.
He would have bare saliva all around his fucking neck.
Oh Jesus Christ.
I've actually thought about that like what do I have dual for?
Bear was running right at me.
I just wished that I would have the wherewithal to run right at it.
Like you know,
if a shark was coming at me,
swim right at it and it as quickly as you can.
Shove your fucking head in there and get it over with.
Okay,
that is the only fucking strategy.
What are you going to climb a tree?
Things going to go right up that tree.
Did you ever see that youtube video of those guys sitting in the tree hunting
that bear and all of a sudden the bear just literally runs up the tree next to
him and is like,
like,
I dunno,
seven feet above them on the tree next to him leaning out,
sniffing at them,
trying to figure out what the fuck they are.
And I love how the bears just instinctual and stay fully know.
It's just like,
like would that bear eight feet above you?
That's like when you're in the upper deck of the stadium,
you know,
and you shit faced and you get into it with somebody two rows behind you,
they automatically have the advantage because they're punching down,
right?
You're gonna lose that fight.
You're going to fall on your back.
You're probably going to break your ankle.
Something's going to get twisted.
Is this guy's punching down at,
you're not.
Just imagine it was a bear.
That was the situation these people are,
and you got to check out that video,
this fucking bear.
It was on the ground and they're whispering in their little fatigues looking at
this thing.
And then this thing,
I don't know how it found them.
You just heard and that was it.
Over this thing was all of a sudden not on the floor of the forest,
20 feet down.
It was now eight feet above them,
sniffing at them like,
Ooh,
is that a food source?
Jesus,
do you really just hit on like two people today hit on two tremendous fears.
I have been alone in the fucking wilderness and and,
and being out to sea.
Fuck both of those,
although I want to hear the stories.
If you do it,
you know,
not if you went on a cruise.
I don't give a shit going out there eating Jello with the date rape drug,
fucking Weirdo,
you know,
to go see the reunion of wham
Cindy Lopper.
I love
[inaudible].
Hey,
what's going on?
Yeah,
spell burn.
It's the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
October 18th,
2010 how the fuck are you?
I'm actually doing this shit Sunday night and I posted it nice and early.
Look at that.
That's a gift for you all.
You can't sit out there bitching about how to actually,
you should call it the fucking Monday after new podcasts.
You know,
I guess maybe you have a point,
but you know what about me?
What about my world?
What about the fact that I record them Monday morning?
So it's still the Monday morning podcast.
All right.
It's fucking free.
I think.
I don't,
I have the right to name the goddamn thing.
Um,
speaking of which,
if you'd like to make a donation to the Monday morning podcast and actually get
a little trinket for yourself,
go to the the m M podcast.com and get the uh,
the Oh Geez.
Ring tone for your phone sales have picked up last week.
F after I kind of broke your guys' balls about saving up for fucking happy
meals.
You can't even kick me fucking 99.
God Damn sense I'm closing in.
This is just like PBS.
I'm closing in on the number that I need to go buy that fucking thing so I can
start walking around doing these three things.
Maybe go to a mall and just,
you can listen to me shit on people for a fucking 45 minutes.
It's actually,
you know,
something that's something I really want to do because,
uh,
yeah,
I don't know.
I like to think I have love in my heart,
but I,
I don't think so.
But anyways,
it was a a,
it was a big week.
I'm just looking at who I wrote for Douche bag of the week and I spelled her
name wrong.
Um,
anyways,
let's talk about the,
uh,
the week coming up and I've actually been talking about this shit on stage and,
I don't give a fuck because it's such a topical bit.
I don't even know if people are gonna think it's funny in a month.
But,
uh,
can we please talk about fucking Bill O'reilly going on the view?
Um,
I gotta I gotta tell you something right now.
I don't like that guy's politics.
I don't like his face.
He has,
he has that racist face.
You know his,
when he gets mad,
his fucking,
his face gets pointy.
He just looks evil.
He's just not a pleasant human being whatsoever,
but I gotta tell you,
he fucking destroyed on the view,
you know,
and I,
somewhere in there was a victory for men because he took on for fucking women.
They were all yelling
and he got two of them to walk off their own fucking show.
How do you do that?
I as a comedian,
I was embarrassed to,
to stand up.
Comic comics just quit,
which is why I'm nominating Joy Bay harbor and Whoopi Goldberg is Douche bags of
the week went,
what did you think was going to,
you think he was gonna go,
no,
wait,
don't leave.
That's exactly what the fuck he wanted you to do.
I was actually hoping at that point that the other two women were going to leave
and then he could just start hosting the O'Reilly factor on the view.
That would have been,
he just totally 100% dominated at the very least,
that segment,
because I don't,
I don't watch that fucking show,
but just,
he just came on.
First of all,
he sits down,
he's got on that shiny fucking Joe Pesci shoot,
Joe Pesci Peshy suit.
It's difficult to say Joe Peshy suit and he's got his fucking leg spread like a
with his ball bag,
hang his shiny ball bay.
He locally,
if you ever see like,
uh,
when Kennedy debated Nixon,
how,
if you listen to it on the radio,
how everybody said Nixon won.
But if you watched it on TV,
Nixon was all tanned up.
He had his legs crossed,
he looked like a winner and Nixon sat there with his fucking legs splayed and
cross like underneath the cherry living a fucking moron.
That's what bill O'Reilly looked like any,
he just,
he still dominated.
I love when he turned to joy and was just whatever I,
I'm paraphrasing here,
but he was just like,
be quiet and learned
and she had nothing,
a fucking standup comic.
She had nothing.
The whole segment was fucking hilarious.
And when he goes,
uh,
another gem of a moment was when he goes,
you know,
a lot of people don't realize this,
but 70% of Americans don't want a mosque at ground zero.
And joy goes.
She goes,
well,
I'd like to see that,
that poll or something like,
and as she's saying that the crowd is applauding what bill O'Reilly just said.
So you really don't need to see the pole at that point.
And,
and getting beyond that,
what he really should have said was 70% of Americans don't realize that they're
not building a mosque at ground zero still,
that they're actually making a rec room with a ping pong table and an area to
pray.
Kind of like they have an area to pray it every fucking airport,
you know,
three,
four blocks up the street at a God damn coat factory is where it's actually
being built.
But the fact that he said that they're still building a mosque and then he got
an applause break.
Joy is so wrapped up into her own fucking opinion that she doesn't even hear her
own studio audience backup the guy that she's trying to shit on.
And the fact that this fucking guy is still putting out inaccurate information,
that people are still backing.
I would,
it just was fucking awesome on all of those levels.
And a,
I like how Barbara Walters was old school.
Cool.
And she didn't walk off.
She gave those two Douche bags of the week shit for walking off their own show.
And then she got him with a nice little class.
He's a singer.
He said,
ah,
Bill O'reilly's on here this week.
When we come back,
we're going to talk,
um,
or he's on the show today.
We're going to,
when we come back,
he's going to talk about his new book called pinheads in Patriots.
And then she looked at bill and she goes,
at this point I uh,
I'm not sure which you are or something like that.
It was a great little zinger,
but she wasn't like judging the guy.
I don't know that the whole thing was funny and just how bill O'Reilly is,
is,
is viewed as this intolerant person.
And then he comes on the show of a,
I guess mostly liberals and then they show absolutely no tolerance for him and
then throw a fucking temper tantrum and walk off their own goddamn show.
I mean,
you can't tell me.
Everybody over at at Fox News wasn't literally jerking off to that moment.
I,
Bill O'reilly almost became a fucking rock star in that moment.
That was,
that was like a standup comic moment that he did to two comedians,
which blew my mind.
You know,
and I know I'm always trashing the broads on this show,
but that really was a chick way of handling,
losing an argument.
Like,
I'm just going to get off up in storm or he is so used to people paying for your
drinks and holding the Goddamn door for you.
You actually thought that as an adult that you were just going to walk off the
shell and this was going to be this big moment.
And he was going to be like,
oh,
wait a minute,
let me stop.
Ah,
I loved it.
He was like,
go ahead and leave.
I don't give a fuck.
I'll continue.
I'll take over your fucking show.
Um,
so anyways,
there you go.
Douche bags of the week.
Joe Bay Har and Whoopi Goldberg for walking off your own fucking show when a
shiny suit fucking,
I can't say he's a moron because he does know.
I mean,
I look,
he,
he's very read up
on that.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I am too stupid.
This is why I wouldn't,
this is right here.
Why I would never engage is much as I disagree with his opinions.
I don't fucking pay attention to politics at all.
I don't,
I find it frustrating.
I find it to be,
it just a rigged fucking gay.
I don't give a fuck,
you know,
and I,
so I would never try to,
as much as I disagree with Bill O'reilly,
I would never go on his show and try to fucking one up the guy and think I'm
going to,
uh,
beat the guy in an argument about politics.
It's like tea.
He's paying attention to these politicians the way I,
I give a fuck about football.
I'm not gonna,
I'm not gonna win that argument.
And we went on,
I bring fucking Roy Jones Jr over and start debating him in about boxing.
I don't know.
It's just,
it was,
uh,
it was fucking hilarious at the whole thing was just,
it was hilarious and a big,
big fucking victory for that fucking,
I dunno.
I Dunno how enough as a stand up comic.
He fucking you just tap out.
That was embarrassing.
Anyway,
let's get on with the Goddamn podcast for this week.
Um,
I kinda liked that you guys liked that format.
Just getting a Douche bag of the week out of the way right off the fucking bat.
Uh,
I know a lot of people in Denver are probably saying that referee who called
dead fucking pass interference on the jets.
I mean on the Broncos,
put them right down there on the goal line to the jets.
Give that guy a game ball or what?
That was fucking hilarious because everybody in New York wanted to kill that
ref.
I can't say it was just him,
but I mean he fucked up to passenger interference calls where the Broncos were
mugging the jets receivers and uh,
what a fucking time for a makeup call.
Huh?
Hey,
you go mark.
You fucking,
he looks like that dude from entourage,
doesn't he?
Look,
I got to extend a fucking olive branch here to the Goddamn jet fans.
I hate the fucking say it,
but you guys got a good team.
I'm convinced now.
All right,
at right now you're probably rolling your eyes and I want you to shut your green
fucking fucking faces for a second.
All right?
This is what I,
I wait til mid October before I start doing,
we're going to win your fucking Superbowl.
That dumb shit that people do in August.
Those people who paint their faces and have horns on their hats and all that
dumb shit,
and you don't wear a shirt to the game in November to show people how crazy you
are because you don't know how to talk to fucking women.
Um,
this is what scares me about the jets as a New York jet hater is,
uh,
not only are they a solid team,
they got luck on this side and you fucking need that.
All right?
Patriot fan.
The tuck rule pulled that one out of the Goddamn fucking mothballs,
wherever that one came from,
you need some luck.
And a,
the jet's got real lucky when the refs finally decided to call a pass
interference they got,
they got and that,
that's the type of shit that happens when you win a championship.
I'm just letting you know jet fans,
cause I know you don't know what that looks like as a jet fan unless you're in
your fucking seventies at this point.
So,
uh,
but I do want to say this to all you conti jet fans and I was going back and
forth with like 20 of them this week.
So I'm sorry if I didn't get back to you.
Um,
all the you shitting on the fucking patriots for getting rid of Randy Moss.
I gotta admit our offense kind of looked the exact same,
you know,
kind of look the exact same and look at Deon branch caught a touchdown fucking
pass and we beat the ravens.
So we're four and one.
I don't know what the fuck that means.
Our defense looked a little bit better,
but I dunno,
this has been the weirdest year in history for NFL football where there's just,
there's nobody dominating.
There's just no front runner team,
you know,
and don't sleep on the fucking a Kansas City patriots out there.
Huh?
Jesus Christ.
They got our old office of coordinator,
defensive coordinator,
old quarterbacks coach and they pulled that fucking play out where you fucking
throw the ball to Mike Graybeal for a touchdown.
Um,
yeah,
but there's,
there's nobody out there.
Raw Steelers came back big Ben.
They got him back.
I stayed away from that game.
I didn't bet it.
I was like,
the fucking steal is 13 points.
They're going to cover that.
But there was something,
I got my stupid theory about division rivalry games.
This is something that's embarrassing.
I'm actually doing this Sunday night,
so I don't even know if the colts one,
I picked the colts,
but I had a,
the colts given three,
but these were the beds I had this week.
And you can follow this all along on the [inaudible] podcast.com me and Paul
Versey heavy season long bet.
We basically,
we were picking three games a week,
but now we're kind of addicted to it.
So now we're kind of up to four.
We're going to pick for each and at the end of the,
against the spread,
the end of the year,
whoever has the,
uh,
the best record wins the pot.
And uh,
I went for,
and one last week I thought I knew some shit in this week.
I got my ass handed to me.
The only game I won I think is the jets game.
I took the jets given three.
I just didn't believe in Denver's fucking quarterback and a,
but I had,
I had Oakland given six go into San Francisco.
I just,
San Francisco keeps shooting themselves in the foot.
Oakland's been paying clinic competitive as fuck it.
I'll take that one.
I lost my ass on that one.
And I went against my gut that has been telling me that Tony Romo is missing
half a fucking chromosome.
And he did,
despite the fact that he throws for 350 yards and the final minutes of the
fucking game,
he just doesn't get it done.
I went against that because I saw what's his face?
Brett Farve grab his goddamn elbow last week during the Monday night game.
So I'm like,
he's an old fuck.
I don't give a shit how many horse tranquilizers they give them a then I kind of
went,
so I lost that fucking game too.
And I gotta admit I have won money on the jets two fucking weeks in a row,
two weeks in a row,
two fucking weeks in a row.
So there you go.
So if you want to follow along and watch our,
uh,
watch our NFL picks and that type of stuff.
I'm actually trying to talk less about the NFL just because I've really,
that's all that I've been talking about,
I feel for like the last two,
three weeks.
So,
um,
and speaking of which,
I actually ran into Nick Swardson then he asked me next time he could come on
here cause he wants to scream about fucking NFL football.
And if you guys think that I am a psycho
when it comes to that Shit,
this guy,
uh,
he really like I was sitting,
I was telling them that bills,
you know,
Bill's jets game or somebody like when I was taking a piss and somebody almost
pushed me into the wall because I was one of my mouth so much.
And I was telling him how I was thinking back afterwards of how I don't want to
end up with my teeth on the floor of a fucking half as NFL stadium.
And he was like,
no,
you did the right thing.
You did the right thing.
You should have talked more shit.
So I got to get them on there cause I think it will be on this podcast.
Do another one of those special ones just because I think it'll be interesting
to,
uh,
hear me try to be a recovered angry fan and uh,
and him saying,
no,
you've got to steer into it.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
let's get with questions this week.
Somebody wrote me here and he said a bill.
Um,
I just got the DVD,
let it go in the mail and it was fucking awesome.
And,
uh,
before I even get going,
I want to thank this guy for by actually buying the DVD.
Um,
and also want to thank all you guys who went out and bought it.
It was actually number one last week,
the number one comedy download as far as standup comedy goes on iTunes.
So I want to thank all you guys and it was fucking huge for me to hear that.
So,
uh,
and then as far as comedy goes,
it was only behind,
uh,
the soundtrack to get him to the Greek.
I don't know where the fuck it is now.
This point might be behind some fucking Nipsey Russell compilation,
but for one day I was number one.
So please keep buying it.
And everybody's saying the same shit who is bought it.
They're like,
wow,
it's even funnier than when I saw on comedy central.
And they took out some fucking
strong bits,
which I really feel that is accurate because they took out 16 minutes of the
special.
So if you think you saw it,
you still haven't seen it.
It's only fucking 10 bucks,
$10 in change.
Um,
so please check it out.
Just so I can sell enough fucking units of this place.
These people I did business with,
we'll actually get in business with me again and want me to do another fucking
special.
It's how it works.
See if they don't make any fucking money.
Next thing you know,
I will be on American idol.
Sit next to Steven Tyler and I'll be fucking,
I dunno,
actually,
I guess I would be on last comic standing.
Wouldn't I?
Have I said anything funny for 20 minutes?
Let's go.
Let's,
let's plow through this.
Anyways,
I just recently started listening to the podcast and whatever,
any fucking ways,
like a conversational,
this guy writes it,
listen to the podcast and shit in any fucking ways.
I like how you talk about pirating music slash comedy and how it's sucks ass.
I'm an independent musician and if I don't sell my singles for 90 cents a
fucking song,
my music career dies.
It doesn't matter that my youtube videos of songs have,
uh,
hundreds of thousands of hits or whatever actual sales mean everything.
I hear Ya.
Cause they will not get back in business with you.
Um,
so anyways,
he goes,
I have a question about alcohol.
Um,
I don't drink that much,
but when I do,
I drink excessively like twice a week.
Usually I blackout.
Nothing bad ever happens.
I just like drinking.
Jesus,
this sounds familiar.
Uh,
he goes on to say,
should I cut back?
I usually clean my,
I usually clean my apartment when I black out.
That doesn't seem bad.
However,
most people think I have a problem for getting that drunk on the weekends.
Uh,
I would appreciate your feedback again.
Let it go.
Was Great.
Worth the 10 fucking dollars.
Well,
thank you once again for buying it.
Um,
yeah,
dude.
All right.
I gotta Tell You,
uh,
I've blacked out from drinking who hasn't?
Um,
and I got it made.
I've always been fascinated.
Oh,
the lovely knee is coming in.
Um,
I've always been fascinated.
It's freezing.
It's freezing in here.
Come on the podcast for a second.
We'll turn the heat on.
Yeah.
Oh,
Jesus.
You know what,
she's,
she just picked up.
She,
I don't know where you got that.
She bought this fucking it like a wooly mammoth pelt.
You're really into first.
Oh my God.
Huh?
Pick up the microphone and talk into it this week rather than,
than me integrate it all.
This is not real far.
Okay.
This is photo.
I got this down to his foe means fake in French.
Oh,
okay.
Jesus.
Look,
you come in here all hoity.
Toity
it's fucking gross.
Yeah,
that looks like that used to be in the back of a van in the 70s and I bet if you
put a fucking ultra violet light over it,
reg Brady's Jesse's is on there from when he banged Florence Henderson.
All right.
I set it.
It's disgusting.
I don't like it like you made that point several times to you,
but not to the listeners.
I think they need to know,
I think 20 times.
Listen,
I'll be the judge of their,
okay.
It's fucking,
it's disgusting.
It's not,
you call it a fabric.
Does Hey,
be quiet and learn something and oh my God,
are you doing the bill O'Reilly?
I'm trying to see if that works on all females because joy just shut up.
You know it's fucked up.
I actually Douche bags of the week.
I actually said Joy Behar and Whoopi Goldberg for walking off their own goddamn
show.
Quitting his standup comedian.
Sell O'reilly in there too,
or just the two of them.
No,
I said that.
I don't agree with his politics,
but he fucking was,
he was the man.
It was their show.
They shouldn't have walked out.
It's true.
It's like you're in my house.
You walk off.
You know what I mean?
It'd be like someone,
you had a house party and some guy came in like breaking shit was being a dick
and then to make him leave you leave your own fucking house.
I can't deal with this anymore.
And you're waiting for him to say no.
So let's get back to this thing.
Can you please stop buying shit like that.
All right.
You know what else she got really going to trash everything you got.
She found this cheetah print.
I didn't find it.
I paid for a yard sale.
You're like fucking peg Bundy.
What do you mean your,
your,
your furniture blankets style that looks animal related.
No,
it's,
it's leopard.
It's,
she found this leopard print sort of table sort of something that you,
it's clearly the print on this basically saying,
you know,
fuck your hoary girlfriend on this.
That's what that says.
And she went out and she got it.
And I'm like,
and she hates that.
Yeah.
And I said,
if you hadn't guessed no and I told you to get the thing fumigated and you never
did fumigated,
whatever the fuck you doing professionally cleaned.
Listen,
I'm trying to help you out.
If you're going to buy something used when it comes to,
it's going to be up against your body or whatever the f are you,
are you going to let me finish my stupid point?
Okay.
Be quiet in learn if you keep doing that kick kicking the ball.
No,
listen to me.
If you're going to do shit like that,
like stay away from leopard prints.
Might.
I like it because that's my taste.
It's not your taste and that's fine.
Okay,
but it we bought it off of some frigging Yuppie googling.
I did.
Okay.
It wasn't like I founded mentioned at halogen areas.
It's wrong with you.
Why don't you just give the Goddamn air?
They live across the street.
They don't live across the street.
You live far away from home off my one stalker trying to throw him off paranoid
about this cause I said
thank you for stopping by the broadcast.
I am dismissing you.
Oh my God.
Your kid,
because you're divulging too much information.
You're cold.
You're wrapped up in that woolly mammoth blanket.
I don't like it.
You're really annoying me.
Just get outta here.
All right.
I'm serious.
I'm dead serious.
Go out to the kitchen and fucking cook something up.
Whip something up there.
Totes.
Yeah.
You don't even believe it,
dude.
Did you turn the fucking heat on?
Cause I smelled that burning smell.
When are we going to step up our life?
I should really take a picture with our life.
That's what I want to do.
I'll tell you because I keep going to people's parties and they're living better
than we are.
This,
this whole debt free life that we're living,
the level of freedom that we have.
Like,
yeah,
it's,
hey man,
let's go see a movie.
And we don't have,
we don't have to work that day that we can take trips than I am.
We both had a white trash upbringing.
I'm not in my house.
More Brash.
Macaroni and cheese was a main dish.
And you hit it with toast.
We used to eat chipped beef on toast.
You didn't have macaroni and cheese and toast for dinner.
Yeah,
we did.
Your mom cooks like it was awesome.
No,
but every once in awhile we would have that as a dinner and I loved it.
We'd have chipped beef on toast.
What?
Beef chipped beef on toast.
It was chips of beef from notes.
Like if,
just imagine if you could freeze a cow,
you skinned it and then you froze,
froze it.
And then you walked up to with a hammer and chisel and you chipped off some beef
and it came in this,
uh,
this mushroomy sort of a,
Oh my God,
what the fuck was that?
It?
Oh my God.
What?
I'm trying to remember the name of that movie.
But it came,
it came in a sauce.
That's what you're saying?
Yeah.
And there was this really having a flashback to my childhood.
We had this other meal that we always involve bread cause it fills you up.
And we had like two pieces of bread and was like this mushroom,
he sorta looking shit that had these little red things in there.
That was fucking gross.
That sounds gross.
Isn't that Cube steaks?
[inaudible] you'd be showing it.
You'd be chewing it like three hours later trying to get that tendon down.
No,
I lived,
uh,
we always had food.
We know we hit,
we had our ups and downs.
My child was like the economy,
there was booms,
there was busts.
But unlike this country,
at some point we hit a level ground and then yeah,
we leveled off,
uh,
around my high school years.
Yeah.
But,
uh,
but it was a good time.
But what I'm saying is,
you know,
what are you saying?
I'm just saying that we're living like we're still eating QC.
Yes we are doing that.
But we,
but my point was though,
you even said,
why don't we have new fucking table that doesn't have just stains on it.
She is stupid trying to have style.
You're ridiculous.
You always think it has a leopard print.
Leopard print equals come Nia.
It equals com podcast.
Know that you think when it comes 30 seconds to wrap this up or vintage thing in
the balls,
I will kick you.
What are you Yoda
in the balls?
I will kick you.
Sorry.
Hacky impression.
I've never even seen that movie.
I've just seen enough hat comedy about star wars.
Give it so forgettable.
Those are the most overrated piece of shit.
You're going to fear the wrath of the star.
Let me take some,
I go back and watch sesame street.
Kermit the frog is still funny.
Timelessly timelessly funny if you get the ones when Jim Henson did it.
Yes.
Okay.
And that time you ever seen that one with that guy comes in and they're trying
to teach you about instruments and he comes into the to the music store and he
goes,
uh,
and he goes,
what can I help you with?
And he goes,
I'd like to buy and he sounds like a trumpet.
And he goes and he goes,
pop,
pop.
Right.
So you're thinking in your head,
you're like,
oh that's a fucking trumpet.
And the dude comes back with like a like a snare drum.
And he goes,
no,
I didn't ask for a,
and then he could make in that they would just have somebody play,
the tone was teaching you about.
But the guy went in the story was hilarious at one point he goes,
oh you're one of those.
Like he kind of gave him a little dig.
There was,
there was something in there for a,
for adults and it's still funny but you go back and you watch star wars unless
you just like reliving a childhood,
which I understand cause I watch NFL highlights and look at football cards.
I do get that,
but I wasn't a Scifi kid,
but I,
I go back and I watch those and they suck.
The acting sucks in that.
The fact that they were doing this movie about you know,
space and the effects at the time it didn't that shit like blow people away.
I thought that was the thing at for it's time.
People were like,
oh my God,
yes.
No,
no,
absolutely.
Absolutely.
But it doesn't,
it doesn't hold up.
Hold up,
hold up.
Like it looks kind of cheesy and like be movie.
No,
like it sucks.
Just really getting to what?
What were we talking about?
I have to get back to the podcast.
All right.
Oh,
I thought this was a part of the podcast.
If you don't stop talking,
I'm going to walk off my own podcast.
That'll show me
in protest.
There are listeners out here,
do they know your opinion of,
you know,
vintage or old items like like a goodwill or a yard sale.
Fucking gross that you feel like people are,
even people either died in it or came on it.
This is seriously what bill thinks when it comes to like vent.
Like I said,
vintage goodwill,
yard sale,
someone either.
The thing is we donate stuff to goodwill all the time.
Have we done any of those things on any of those things that we,
God,
I can't believe you're saying yes.
No we haven't.
I'm gonna tell you right now,
there's not a t shirt that I own.
I give a talk.
Oh my gosh.
You've watched the to stop.
Well,
you need to stop asking the questions.
I never did anything grows in like the clothes that I donate to goodwill or
whatever can be prayed.
I listen to you if you're not going to be honest on the podcast.
Completely honest.
Look at,
first of all,
you go down there and then all that God damn estate jewelry with those broaches
that somebody's dead grandmother's stuff.
So what?
That's fucking creepy.
So what do you,
what do you propose people do throw it in the trash?
No,
I don't know.
I'm not,
people can do whatever they want.
I'm just,
I just don't want you wearing some fucking Jack Klugman old trench coat.
Oh,
fucking itchy and it's just gross.
It's fucking gross.
We have the money to buy new clothes.
Go by him.
I like certain vintage clothes.
A lot of people do.
It's a style thing.
All right.
You need to not be such a snob about it.
No,
I don't.
I'm not a snob.
I am not.
As you talk about us not stuffing it up a,
your snobby about stuff.
Any stepping it up is having nice shit near not grabbing a leopard fucking come
table off the goddamn sidewalk.
If you don't stop.
It's nice.
I like it.
It brings me happiness.
And just because you don't like it doesn't mean that I'm not allowed to be
happy.
All right,
you're warmed me up.
You one.
All right,
well thank you for stopping by the podcast.
No,
I have to give,
I have to give because I already,
I talked to Greg,
Greg Fitzsimmons on the special one.
So I've already had guests.
I try to,
I try to do the guest thing every once in awhile and uh,
you're a little pouty face is not going to influence me either way.
Fine.
Um,
do me a favor,
go out and,
uh,
go get me some ice cream or something.
Can you,
what's that?
What's that shit that the Italians make?
They're that awesome stuff.
Gelato.
I'm not going to get your gelato.
Why?
Because you kicked me out and you're cold hearted.
What if I asked?
Really Nice.
It's really nice tasting.
Oh,
I asked nicely.
So what if I ask nicely?
It's too late.
You're not even asking.
You haven't yet.
You haven't given me a chance.
I'm leaving.
Yeah,
it's been real.
Listen,
he looked so beautiful right now and I was wondering,
Hey,
you go see.
That's how you get rid of your girl.
IED was ask her to do you a favor and they storm out of the room.
So there's another one for you.
Um,
all right,
let's get to underrated.
Overrated this week.
How far into this fucking part?
31.
Fucking God.
Damn minutes.
Actually speaking of reliving your childhood?
Um,
I actually every once in awhile go through like I,
I'm really big on the NFL in the 1970s and I own complete,
uh,
sets of football cards basically from the late seventies to the early eighties,
which was basically when I was of the age when I should have been collecting
football cards all the way to the age where I was almost getting a driver's
license.
And it was getting a little weird and my parents were worried that either I was
a going to live at home for the rest of my life or bring a gun to school.
One of the other,
um,
let me get rid of this.
Close this window here.
Let's get to underrate it.
Overrated for the week here.
Um,
overrated,
underrated,
overrated.
This persons,
and this is for all any new listeners out there of my podcast,
which I doubt I'm going to have for well because evidently iTunes is done with
me.
And I know there's a lot of people,
if you already subscribed,
this was the confusion last week with Brad is um,
if you are already subscribed to my podcast on iTunes for some fucking reason,
you can still get the podcast each week.
But if you're a new listener and you search for the podcast,
it's not there anymore.
If anybody knows,
any computer savvy people out there knows away that I can guide new listeners to
find where my podcast is on.
Um,
iTunes.
I would really appreciate it.
Um,
I don't know if it's because you clicked on my website.
This is all shit my web guy handles so I have no fucking idea.
Please help me up,
won't you please.
All right.
Overrated.
Underrated for the week.
Lady Gaga and this guy says a or this woman,
I don't have no idea.
Why is it she can dress like a slim Jim Mascot and sing about being a cock tease
and everyone thinks she's brilliant,
that they listened to her lyrics and stopped telling me she's beautiful on TV
and in magazines.
I'm sick of being told what to find attractive.
I don't know where they get their standard,
but this bitch is ugly.
Granted she has a nice ass from what I can tell by the rolling stone cover,
but I bet it's not even her real one.
A while I'm added,
Brittany Spears is ugly to where does the media get its taste in women from uh,
c'mon man.
Back in the day Brittany wasn't hot,
you know,
before she went crazy and her head and rob that seven 11 or whatever the fuck
she did.
Um,
you know,
something they might,
they might actually fix her up a little bit because I thought that,
um,
remember that video she did was she just wore the all red,
uh,
latex outfit.
She looked like a fucking midget.
I don't know what it was about that.
Was she not wearing high heels?
She looked like,
like how she would look like the morning after,
after you fucked her and you've got to see what she really looked like.
You know,
you know my theory about the,
the whole,
uh,
you know,
women with high heel shoes and you're thinking,
oh my God,
look at this girl.
She looks like a supermodel and then you get them home,
you get them out of the shoes in ft had done doing what you do when they get up
to go get some water or go to the bathroom.
You just see this midget and a thong waddle and across the fucking floor.
Um,
she,
that's what she looked like in that video.
Oh Jesus sees this is why I don't do fuck this.
You know something for all you cunts who give me shit about how the podcast is
late every week.
This is why I don't do it Sunday night cause I'm burned out from watching
fucking sports or I flew on an airplane and it's never funny.
This is the only part of the podcast that ends up being funny is me talking
about how fucking on funny it is.
All right,
let's plow ahead.
Did I tell you guys it was raining out here today and how every Douche bag out
here,
the second it starts raining in La,
they start driving like this six inches of snow on the ground.
Evidently it's because it never rains out here.
That all the oil,
transmission fluid and all that just sits there in marinades on the street.
And I guess when it rains,
it makes it extra slippery,
more slippery than it would be in an area where it actually rains.
But these fucking,
it's still not that fucking slippery.
Um,
continuing on,
these are just ideas.
These aren't even jokes.
I'm just presenting premises that maybe one day I'll be able to make funny.
Jesus Christ,
um,
underrated pit bulls.
Uh,
it fucking burns me up to see all the bad press pitbulls get because some
horrible luck,
abused one
wet get because some horrible fuck abused one into killing into a killing
machine yet again that not like that.
I have one and he's a fucking marshmallow.
You know how since,
uh,
you,
you should know since you have one too.
They're great dogs.
Um,
I like most dog breeds except for the one that the tiny ones,
but pitbulls especially make great dogs.
They're the chosen breed of evil fucks,
I admit,
but on their own,
they're nothing dangerous.
It's funny to see people at Warrior around my dog sometimes,
but it's also kind of sad.
Yeah,
I would go with that.
But also I think that,
um,
you should get some sort of training before you get either a pit bull,
a German shepherd,
a a,
a Doberman Pinscher and even like a Labrador or any of those fucking dogs
because
I dunno,
they kind of,
I've learned through taking my dog to one of these dog whisperer people,
they really feed off you vibes.
And as you noticed,
I'm sort of an angry amped up guy.
So you know,
I'm not going to get into the fucking details,
but I've had to definitely adjust my behavior.
My dog's fine now,
but it got a little shady there for a second.
Um,
overrated.
The Disney channel as far as I can tell on passing by this channel.
Sometimes it's,
it's uh,
oh fuck.
See,
now I'm yawning on the podcast.
This is all you cons.
Who give me shit every week to do it fucking Sunday night.
Um,
as far as I can tell on passing by this,
this channel,
um,
it's a preteen porn ring.
They take these 12 to 14 year old girls and dress them slutty and cover them and
makeup and then tell them to act twice their age.
Jesus,
what is with these shows where the kids are fucking 14 and they have problems.
I didn't have till I was in my twenties.
I was a moron when I was 14 and so was everyone else.
I didn't do shit with my life.
Um,
then and neither did anyone.
It's disgusting.
And it's a farce what they do to these girls.
You make in my Dick Confuse thinking,
I'm looking at a grown woman when I'm not.
Thank you.
Lead me into 10 teeth.
Uh,
lead me not into temptation.
Disney channel.
And You wonder why there are so many pedophiles.
Um,
I don't think Disney's the reason why,
uh,
there's so many pedophiles,
but I do agree they're subtly making programming for them.
I don't even know if that's fucking true.
I shouldn't even say that shit.
But I will say like Calvin Klein,
if I was to guess is,
uh,
100% pro pedophile and,
I think that he had a meeting at some point and was like,
you know what,
there's an entire segment of the human population that is not getting their
needs taken care of when it comes to advertising and that is the fucking
pedophiles.
So with that,
let's come up with an ad campaign.
Underrated legendary comedians.
Bill as a comedian yourself,
I'm sure you have nothing but respect for legends like Carlin prior or Lenny
Bruce,
Lenny Bruce.
But Carlin gets dismissed so often in favor of,
of the hacks they have out there today.
Uh,
for the most part,
the only thing most people know about him is that he,
he's the seven dirty words guy.
Really,
that's how we honor a 50 year career of a comedy legend with obscure bit he did
in the 70s.
I know there was a supreme court case over it and whatnot,
but it just bothers me to see how many kids today know all about hack comics.
Like,
I'm not naming names and they've never heard of Carlin prior Bruce Hicks or
their work.
It's nice that there are comedians out there.
Uh,
okay,
now he's complimenting me so I can't read that shit.
All right.
Uh,
yeah,
I mean it is what it is.
It's one of those deals where,
you know,
uh,
I think I knew who Carla was when I was a kid because he was,
he was at the height of his career when I was coming up in the 70s and the 80s.
Um,
but I had no idea who Lenny Bruce was until I got into stand up comedy,
um,
at,
that's just,
I think that's just part of being young.
It is annoying.
I actually talked to one of my cousins the other day who's in her early
twenties,
and,
uh,
I mentioned the kids in the hall in both her and her boyfriend had no idea who
or what that was.
It just,
I don't know.
It is what it is.
Overrated.
Beautiful women.
Um,
I don't mean because they're prone to deception.
I mean,
because some women are two beautiful in this sort of unfuckable kind of way that
just ruined a woman,
has to be at least a little flood.
So you feel like you can violate her son.
It's helping with a beautiful woman anyways because you drive yourself crazy
thinking everyone wants what you have.
It's better to be with someone you learn,
you learn to find attractive in your own way,
and no one else can see it.
All right?
Uh,
Oh shit.
Okay,
these are,
here's his opinions.
That's a self esteem issue right there on your part.
You know?
But I do understand,
do you know what it is when a girl is just so,
it's not all,
it's a combination of,
of beautiful and just nice.
They can be met.
A girl who's just so beautiful and so nice and you're so fucked up and twisted
that you can't have sex with her.
You just can't.
You're like,
I don't want to fuck you on what?
To take you to a movie,
you know?
And then you meet some skank and you're like,
I'm gonna take you to a movie.
I want to fucking bend you over the dresser.
I believe that's a hormone Donna complex.
Am I the only one who feels that way?
I'm trying to think of if somebody on TV that you could relate to that's just
nice.
You know who's borderline is that fucking goofy chick who cooks Rachel Ray.
She's borderline.
So sort of like nice and innocent that you couldn't,
but it's literally that quality that just makes you want to fucking,
you know,
I dunno,
I get involved in it.
Oh Gee,
here's,
let's continue underrated having a fun job.
This one is aimed at you,
Bill.
You like to bitch about how uh,
midgets insert midgets more on stones,
et Cetera.
Don't want to work often enough.
Can I clarify that stoner thing?
I made fun of a specific person.
A friend of mine who smokes way too much weed and every stone are out there.
Fucking sent me these emails.
We mean,
what do you got against?
Or I guess cause I imitate you like that,
but what the fuck?
That's the standard voice for you.
You find me a pot movie where someone doesn't talk like that and I'll do a
better impression.
But that's what everybody says.
How come you always cut me down,
bud hedge me in.
I'm not,
I'm coming down on my fucking douchebag friend who all he's done is smoked weed
and it hasn't been a good thing for him.
His quote,
I like to smoke weed because it turns my life into a movie.
All right,
you have a problem at that point.
Now all you fucks who liked to smoke weed and listen to this shit?
I don't give a fuck.
I drink.
Wouldn't that be hypocritical?
And speaking of which,
I'm on the wagon again,
as of today,
I did not drink today.
Everybody and a,
I'm going to try and see if I can make it all the way to the rose bowl before I
fall off the fucking work.
And again,
it's yawning once again.
No,
I don't know what it is.
I um,
I just been eating the wrong foods and uh,
I dunno.
And every night I've just been doing sets and I've had two Heinekens and next
scene.
Oh,
I have this distended white belly and I'm not liking it.
You know,
I was just at a party and I wasn't drinking,
but I was leaning up against the counter and normally it would be digging into
my back.
But I had a nice,
a nice level of padding,
you know,
from fucking,
you don't really screwed me up was when I went to buffalo,
the goddamn buffalo wings was so good there that I have gone on a buffalo wing
kick and I found a couple of places out here that have really good buffalo
wings.
And um,
actually you don't want to hear the story.
This is what happened.
Um,
I woke up on Saturday and I'm getting another ca or Saturday as they say in
Boston,
in Boston when the real hardcore Boston guys,
you know,
I saw him on Saturday.
You just sort of open your mouth
sachet Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday,
Sunday.
Say,
um,
I woke up and I'm thinking,
all right,
college football,
Auburn,
verse Arkansas.
Lsu was plain McNeese state.
They're given 39 and a half points,
so they're going to fucking cover the spread.
Who else was playing Georgia?
Was playing,
Vanderbilt was all fucking site and we're laying in bed.
My beautiful girl wakes up and she said,
uh,
and she claimed the fucking TV.
It's like I'm watching TV.
So I immediately got up,
acted like I was going to the bathroom,
and I walked out,
sat in the living room,
and I turned on the fucking and I started watching,
uh,
who the fuck was blessed or watching the Auburn Arkansas game,
which was fucking ridiculous.
You know,
Arkansas end up scoring like 40 something points and they still lost by 20.
It was absolutely insane.
And so she's like,
Hey,
I said,
it's gonna Watch TV.
[inaudible]
right?
So I tried to bill O'Reilly,
I tried to do that and it just didn't work.
Didn't work.
All right.
She had a rough week.
She wanted to watch your stupid reality shows.
So I said,
fine.
I said,
All right.
And uh,
I,
I grabbed my stereo,
one of my stereo speakers was busted.
So I took it down to this fucking local guy.
Sky's out of his God damn mind.
He actually repairs shit.
So I already loved the guy.
So I go down there,
I get that taken care of.
I know I,
what else did I do?
I went out,
I just,
I just fixed some shit.
I went out and I bought some stuff.
I fixed some shit around the apartment and I let her watch the shit.
And at one point I was picking up dry cleaning.
I was doing all these God damn chores and I just saw this fucking,
uh,
this bar and I knew they had wings and I was literally going to go in to get dry
cleaning.
I was parked in the dry cleaner parking lot and I look across the fucking way
and there's a bar with wings and I get out like,
uh,
like the Manchurian candidate.
Like they just turned on my chip and I walked across the street and the bar and
next thing you know,
I'm sitting there,
I've got a water,
they got a Boddingtons and I got a fucking order of a dozen wings and I'm
tearing these fucking things down.
Like I'm in a wings Eaton contest.
Here I am consuming 800 fucking calories or whatever the hell it was.
1200 goddamn calories for no fucking reason.
Cause I don't want to bother my girl because she's watching.
She's watching a fucking shows.
So I do all his shit.
I ended up stumbling out of there and then I finally,
uh,
go over to get the God damn dry cleaning
and I come back,
right.
And during that time a buddy of mine text me said,
Hey,
I'm in la.
Are you watching the Ohio state game?
I said,
well,
it's going to be on TV.
Why don't you come by?
I figured,
cause my girls watched three hours of fun.
I have to whisper this Parker,
she's going to get mad.
I figured because she watched three hours of fucking TV that I could actually
have a friend over,
but like douche rather than saying,
hey,
you know,
you watch TV for three hours.
So I'm going to have a buddy of mine over here now and we're going to watch the
I,
hi,
hi.
Oh State Wisconsin game.
I actually gave her the benefit of the,
of the doubt that she was going to be courteous and I said,
hey,
a friend of mine's coming over to watch your house state game.
You know,
we can either watch it here or would you rather us watch it out at a bar?
cause I thought she was going to be like,
well know I hogged the TV for three hours.
You know,
why don't you watch it here and I'll leave you guys alone.
She didn't.
She goes,
yeah,
go watch it as sports bar.
So now I was pissed.
You know like when you have like one slice of pizza left and you offer it to
somebody going,
hey,
do you want this slice of pizza even though you want it cause you're thinking
they're going to go,
no,
no.
That's okay because that's what you would say.
And you go,
hey,
would you like to slice of pizza?
And they go,
actually I would.
And then they start eating.
Then you sit in there for your fucking mad at them when you should be mad at
yourself like an asshole.
I got mad at her right and we had time to do a quick workout.
I just made some fucking wings and she wanted to go on a hike.
So we start to go on this hike and I just start going on to the,
on this rant about this stupid whore TV shows that she fucking walked watches
and we got about a third into the hike in,
she was like a wide receiver,
just breaking off her fucking pattern.
She just made a right down.
We were supposed to be walking straight.
She,
she broke off,
made a right and started walking down a side street and I didn't even give a
fuck.
And I continued my own way and we both were hiking um,
separately,
you know,
broke off the whole fucking thing.
We ended up getting this huge goddamn argument before my friend came over and
then there was that whole thing like a fuck.
Now I've got to patch it up before he comes over.
So he doesn't feel the tension that we've been fucking arguing.
And not only we arguing,
we're arguing about fucking him coming over.
So I smoothed it over.
She came back,
I said,
look,
I fucking overreacted,
Yadda,
Yadda.
Yet I didn't know that I even have a fucking ending.
I don't give a fuck.
I'm just going to keep saying it's because it's Sunday.
I'm going to read one more fucking email and I'm just going to tap out of this
awful fucking podcast.
What was the point of that?
Can anybody even remember where the fuck was I even go,
I've started talking about about eaten wings and being out of shape and then the
end of it,
I told a fucking half ass story about getting into an argument.
Now he can't even sign into my fucking this,
this,
this podcast is literally just unraveling,
unraveling.
I don't even drink today.
The fuck is my podcast.
Here's a youtube video of the week.
If you guys are like,
if you play drums and you want to see a guy who actually can kind of make his
drums and the way he plays sounded like John Bonham's guys does a great job.
Look up John Bonam swing feel,
feel f e e l and uh,
and tell me the guy playing drums does not look like a,
was it ogre?
What was the name of the,
the the fucking psycho in revenge of the nerds.
Tell me that's not him.
Um,
but hang on a second.
I got gotta get back here because I wanted to read something about douchebag
sports fans and then I'm going to end the podcast for this week.
This one really sucked,
but I got him at the last couple of weeks were pretty good.
But this one,
this one was not good in the annals of Bill Burke podcast.
You know this one will not make it to repeat if the,
if this ever goes into syndication,
somebody sent me a great fucking email.
Oh I know why.
Cause I had it on this page
about sports fans.
Right?
I'll tell you what it is.
I'm searching for this fucking thing that I can't find anymore.
God Damn can't.
Um,
here we go.
Here's some youtube videos out called reason to kill.
All of these are on the Mlm podcast cause some of these are actually from
break.com and a.
So rather than have to jump around websites,
if you want to watch all these,
um,
out cold reason to kill,
uh,
this is like inexplicably this fucking video,
this a singer,
he's on the ground in,
there's a fan doing something to him that I just can't believe,
and they proceed to have the worst fist fight in the history of,
of fist fights.
Uh,
look up Kendall on sharecropping field trip
one slap Kao at gas station that's actually from break.com and then look up
massive knockout.
Those things that kind of violent.
What the fuck did I do with the goddamn email?
This kid sent me,
this guy sent me a great email about as much as people hate the patriots,
they hate the cowboys more.
So we actually kind of,
I give up.
You know what I just fucking give up on this God damn podcast.
All right,
here's where I'm going to be this week.
you fucking pricks.
I'm going to be at,
uh,
the Wilbur Theater in Boston,
Massachusetts.
Uh,
on Wednesday of this week,
this is a fundraiser for my brothers,
uh,
campaign.
He's running for a state Senate in Massachusetts,
not to be in the United States Senate representing Massachusetts,
but I guess they have a different kind of senator just in Massachusetts.
I'm too fucking dumb.
So whatever I'm going to do at a comedy show at the Wilbur Theater,
it's my brand new hour of material.
All proceeds will go to my brother's campaign to try to help him get elected.
I'm so come on down,
even if you're not in his district,
which I don't even know what the fuck it is.
Uh,
come on down and,
uh,
maybe tell,
be telling a lot of family stories
and uh,
trying to walk that line
so I don't offend too many people because it is kind of a political thing.
Uh,
and later on this week,
I will be at the pantageous theater in,
uh,
Minneapolis,
Minnesota on October 22nd,
and the,
a wonderful,
talented teen idols sensation from the opiate.
Anthony showed Joe de Rosa.
We'll be opening for me.
And then the following day we're going to be at the Vic Theater in Chicago,
Illinois.
October 23rd,
um,
that show from what I've heard is actually sold out.
Um,
and I think the one in Minneapolis is coming damn close.
So I'm going to thank you guys for the ridiculous amount of support that you've
given me and I'm going to give you a fucking hell of a show when you come down
there.
And uh,
I think that's it.
I think that's it for the podcast this week.
It is,
was one of the lamest ones I think I've ever done.
Let me,
let me see if I can just somehow pull out of it.
Do I got anything?
This thing this guy sent me.
Robots are stealing jobs.
Robots are stealing American jobs according to MIT economist.
Uh,
forget the recession.
Immigration and the mortgage industry collapse.
Well,
okay.
Why?
How can you forget all of those?
Okay.
This is already a ridiculous article,
but I think there was a point to be made here when it comes to the loss of
American jobs.
Robots are to blame.
And you know what's hilarious?
They got a picture of a robot with fucking arms folding a goddamn sweater.
Um,
that's the conclusion of a con economist.
Do you understand in the future that when you have a robot,
not only can it fold the sweaters at the gap,
it can also be security.
You know,
didn't you guys see robocop?
Can't you see what the fuck is gonna Happen?
All you morons who are using these automated checkout machines just helping
these fucking guys.
Do you think these corporations are beyond leading you to a shallow mass grave
when they don't need you anymore?
When they figure out how to make a robot that can actually work for free and,
and you can actually fuck it in.
It feels like a human being.
When those two things come together,
uh,
like when they drove that golden spike in,
when they made the railroads connect,
I'm telling you that's the end of it for you and for me.
Huh?
Be honest with yourself.
Are you inventing anything?
What do you do for a living?
Do you think you're not replaceable?
They could.
You don't think they could have a robot.
They just fucking upload every goddamn routine of all time and you just,
you can just have like a a computer screen topics,
political,
absurd hacky,
what you know,
women,
men and women,
dogs and cats,
all that type of shit.
Or just have it to a Richard Pryor bit and have it move around like Richard and
they have a red fucking shirt on like that.
Great.
Specially did.
We're all fucking replaceable.
All right,
why are you going to help him out anyways?
They say that's the conclusion of economist who studied Labor Statistics and
increasing job peril polarization or growing disparity in the pay among low and
high skill,
low and skilled jobs.
A handful of studies from the spring and summer have picked up steam in recent
weeks and they raised some interesting questions about the economy in the days
leading up to election day.
By the way,
how great have I become reading out loud?
This is fucking amazing.
Now that I've said it,
let's see if I'm in my head and I fuck up.
Manufacturing is still strong in this country.
It's just that robots,
not humans are the ones manning the factories.
If automation is the future of manufacturing and medicine in other fields,
less educated Americans could be left in the dust.
I gotta be honest with you.
I don't write the way they just worded that.
I don't know where I stand on that.
Um,
I'm definitely think the world is overpopulated.
See this,
this,
this enters like that.
Fucking Hitler Shit.
You're gonna have to start deciding who gets the live and who doesn't.
A Jesus.
Oh Geez.
So I dunno.
I actually took my fucking speakers,
right?
I found this guy down the goddamn street.
Somehow.
I'm going to stretch this into an hour.
I've got another two minutes.
I found this guy down the street
who I had,
you know,
you know the thing that you stick your iPod on and it's got the speakers and
that type of shit.
When I think broke one day and it just doesn't work.
So Nia is just like,
well,
we'll just throw it out.
And I go,
no,
I want to get it.
I want to get fixed.
And she's like,
oh,
she literally gets like upset and I'm like,
there's probably just a fucking wire or something.
I just don't understand electronics.
He could just open it up,
you could fix it,
and I find this fucking guy,
the first thing I did was had these old speakers that I hook up to my laptop and
so I go,
all right,
I don't give a fuck about these.
I'm going to take them down to this guy.
Am I going to figure out if this guy is any good or anything and the guy fixes
them,
they fucking phenomenal.
So what I'm doing is I'm gradually bringing this guy more expensive shit.
All right.
Now that's what I suggest.
When you find a guy who says he's going to repair your shit,
start with something you don't give a fuck about like a clock radio.
All right?
Let them repair it.
And if it works,
you're all fucking good,
right?
Because I'm all about this shit by the way.
He's,
when something breaks,
you go out and you get it fixed because evidently there is a pile of shit in the
middle of the Pacific Ocean.
One and a half times the size of Texas in two miles deep of all the shit that we
just fucking throw out.
All right.
And then the sun breaks down the plastic as much as it can,
right?
And it becomes these little cubes in birds eat it and fucking fishing it.
And then you go down and eat,
order some Sushi and you think you're eating healthy.
You're actually eating year old fucking roller blades.
So I'm all about fixing this shit.
So this fucking maniac,
he's like really like eccentric.
His places an absolute fucking mess.
And he was talking about,
I don't want to give away his idea here,
but I'm kind,
kinda going to talk cause he was talking about how all recorded music since the
beginning of history is a fucking lie.
I'm like what?
What are you talking?
These are the kinds of conversations you have when you go into a fucking mom and
pop kind of place.
You know it isn't like Coes Nax can I help complains on salary therapy.
We can't kids there anything else I can help you with.
This guy isn't like that.
He's telling me this shit and he basically broke it down saying that he works
Monday through Saturday fixing electronics shit.
And on Sunday he goes on the Internet
and he looks up the heights of,
of like Jimi Hendrix,
all the beetles and he tries to learn how tall they are so he can figure out
where to position his speakers.
And I'm like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
He goes,
look,
he goes Simon and Garfunkel,
he's like Garfunkel was five 11 Paul Simon's like five seven and a half,
whatever for you,
you'd like new,
their exact heights.
He goes,
but when they do the mix they mix them like do the exact same height.
So He's trying to tell me that you've got to put one speaker at five foot 10 or
11 and the other at five foot seven and a half to really sat.
Hear what it sounds like if they were actually in the room singing to you.
And when you really think about acoustics,
that actually fucking makes sense.
I know a lot of you are going like,
what the fuck?
But I'm telling you,
this guy broke it down where it made sense because think about it like if I was
standing,
if I was sitting down,
if your ears were good enough,
if you heard a recording of me sitting down or if you stay sitting in a room
with your eyes closed,
you could tell if I was sitting down or standing up in the room because you
could because of the way the sound was hitting you.
But when I guess when they record the shit,
they level everything out.
Like the drums don't sound like they were behind the piano player or off to the
left.
I guess everything sounds,
you know what?
I'm too stupid to explain this shit.
All I know was the guy in front of me.
He fixed this guy so he doesn't just fix your speaker.
He asked you if he wants you to hook it up and do it the right way.
Same thing with like amps and guitars and I don't have the balls to bring in my
amplifier.
I'm trying to see if this guy is true.
But he basically played steely Dan out of one of this guys speakers and it
sounded like two speakers.
The sound was fucking unbelievable.
So,
uh,
once again,
I don't know what the point of my fucking story was there.
Other than fuck robots fucked.
Let me wrap this whole thing up.
Fuck by an old furniture that has leopard print on it cause it's got TJ's on it.
Guaran fucking teed and if something breaks down,
why don't you try and get it fixed?
Speaking of which,
the blinds in my apartment,
my dog attacked him,
like 90 of them are okay,
but I need some new slots.
Can anybody tell me where the fuck to buy those?
Because I want to repair them.
Once again,
Nia wants me to throw out the fucking things and just go buy some brand new ones
and it's like,
well what about the,
where the fuck did the,
do my other blinds go?
Where do we,
where the fuck did those go?
That'd be a great documentary.
He just throw something out.
You'll put a microchip on it and you just follow it.
You know,
if he gets somehow find the thing that ended up in the ocean,
that a fucking,
uh,
a p a tuna inhaled and then go to the restaurant
and just blow sad.
If we wouldn't fucking work,
would it,
you know what this podcast is like?
There's a bad thing that comedians do when they're not getting laughs and they
just think the next joke's going to get him a fucking laugh.
And they,
and they just stay on stage and they stand.
I should have tapped out at 50 minutes and just,
and just been like,
I've proven my point that when I do podcast on Sunday night is nice as it is,
that when you come in on a fucking Monday,
that there's already a podcast waiting for you at work.
The little fucking nice little ribbon tied around it.
It's just not as good is when I do them after I have a good night's sleep,
you know?
So,
uh,
there you go.
Overrated bill doing podcasts.
The Monday morning podcast on a fucking Sunday night.
I'm not doing this shit anymore.
All right.
Go Fuck Yourself.
If you want me to do it,
I don't give a shit.
All right.
That's it.
I gave you an hour and five minutes.
None of a hundred percent mediocrity.
I started off.
All right.
But I think in general,
this one sucked a big bag of elk dick,
as they say in comedy business.
All right.
That's it.
That's the part.
That's the podcast for this week.
And,
uh,
I'll talk to you next week on Monday morning and you can fucking wait for their
can face.
Okay.
[inaudible].